I'm not too busy for you MS know
whatever one you want I'll try tomorrow
too busy for Mumbai to know this is what
I got I came on my break I had a break
right now and I went to rosenberger I
went in there this morning I know and
I'm looking at my schedule for media
yeah in Rosenbergs first okay that's
good we're doing it first we're kind of
nice little morning sugar and then right
I look and there's no there's no Sam
there's so many other words Sam yeah and
they go they go my people go he's too
busy today and I went I went what he's
too busy
he's too big they should have been more
down there you know they were more
delicate you tell me your Excuse tell me
why that you were too busy for me to
come in and interview me
I'm coming on my break I'm not even
supposed to be here right now you're
saying I want his excuse to see me in
person I want you to tell me to my face
yeah why you're too busy for me today
well I didn't know you were about 25
right is this Monday the biggest show
that Rawls ever doing right now we're
closed for do a man answer you're gonna
be that I want you're too busy for me
Friday I didn't know you know what I'm
doing media in New York City grunts
you're too busy for me you didn't tell
me it was important he didn't eat heard
you were gonna be your Excuse no I was
told I know you don't feel you know
you've known me long enough you can
reach out to me you could reach out to
you tell me why you're too busy for me
and tell me your whole story I want the
whole lie I mean we were talking about
Tide Pods for like a half-hour this
morning before you watch you know talk
about what's the tide pod challenge the
what kids are in tide pods
that's pets why don't you take it for me
doing before you too
here's Valley are you too busy for me
here's what happened I didn't know
you're gonna be in town until I was
listening to hot 97 when I drove in this
morning and I was like Miz is in town
who are your people because your people
already told my people right I mean I
can't believe you have people I have
money I can that you get other people by
the way I walked in here yeah you're
alone
yeah but I walk in and 50 people walk in
yeah cameras and everything taking
pictures right you're nobody until I
come in I so how are you too busy for me
no I didn't know damn stop lying I know
top lying I did not know really you're
really making me mad I don't want you to
man I want to know why yeah then stop
saying you didn't know you did no I did
not know you're gonna be in town you did
know I was gonna be a be you're too busy
for me well they said they told me they
said it to my face right they said what
did you say get on the mic get on the
mic here's what happened I didn't find
out you're in town until this morning
and I got a text this morning saying hey
miss you know did you fun did anybody
tell you the MS was gonna be here I said
no but I would always have the MS in
does he want to come in right and then
they go oh yeah but who's in today and I
said I got Bruce Prichard and Eric
Bischoff already booked they're coming
in right at 9:45 they're more important
than me
and you know your community they're more
important but I'm going to be a cancel
I'm in a main event match on Monday at
raw 25 20 15 over sir I've been in WWE
for 12 years and I'm going for the
intercontinental champions chip with
against one of the biggest stars that
WWE has offer and I'm one of the biggest
stars you have WB has offer and we're
gonna collide right at at brawl 25 and
and I'm not big enough for this show no
that's not true here to what you just
told me already have two people on I
don't need another one that's what
you're saying is what I heard I heard I
said I've already told Bruce Prichard
and Eric Bischoff that they can come in
at 9:45 you can't call people and be
like well now you can't come in day of
because nobody told me the Miz was in
town so I said if Miz wants to come in
before I'd love to have him that's when
you're here so you're telling me that
that if you choose to who's the biggest
star the biggest get for this show ever
besides me the biggest star we've ever
had on the fair but like the biggest get
the biggest get do we add like know that
you'd want that you'd be like oh my god
De Niro
do you ever hear Robert De Niro calls up
and says I want to be on the Sam Roberts
show what are you gonna do
I just hate it busy I'd say
I'd say five it's Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts just cuz he's not here doesn't
mean you take his name off :
would you say you're too busy for De
Niro yeah for me I said let's make it
work first yes this is this this is what
you do Sam this is what you do at Radio
Row two years ago at WrestleMania you
snubbed me I hear when Jim Norton
abdomen prepared for you and Jim Norton
I was like oh I can't wait to go on
their show I love them so much I
listened to him great and you guys
snubbed me then I come back here
Norton's nowhere to be found
no he's not here I had I had to talk to
Ronald Funches and and and listen to him
how he wants to be a WWE Superstar and
that's wonderful great guys I love them
to death and now I come here right and I
walk in and you're by yourself talking
about some sort of what is it again it's
the tide Pied Piper yeah for me yeah
well I say I mean you're here
unbelievable this is my break they said
they said they said hey mez you know we
only have this amount of break I go
we're going to Sampson where I don't
care what your world barging in where
I'm taking over his show because the
fact is he's too busy for me but if I
was to Nero if I was to Nero robertinho
yeah oh you know oh I'm not big enough
for you is what you're saying no no
d-list and my C list is is my new
unscripted show on USA that's gonna be
coming out very shortly miz and miz's
not big enough his money not wrong I'm
not big enough is the marine six
close-quarters not big enough is the
challenge where I'm hosting is that not
big enough or my social media platforms
not big enough I'm just curious what is
not big enough for Sam freakin Roberts
similar in six is not as big a deal as
Goodfellas was you know just putting
that you know you can't the marine six
wasn't it's a big deal but it's not as
big as Goodfellas it's to some people it
is a big deal no I in it to me it's a
big deal I know Shawn Michaels is in it
Lynch toe Becky Lynch that it you like
Becky Lynch right not Becky you love
like I love you but tell her that tell
you wouldn't tell her that you wouldn't
tell Shawn why could you tell me that
because you're a jerk I'm not a jerk as
Shawn Michaels wouldn't come to me and
say like Robert De Niro III know what
Michaels wanted to come into the show
would you would you would you say you're
too busy he's been on
would you say you're too busy I didn't
say I'm would you say you're too busy I
said how do we work you said you're too
busy they say you were too busy I just
want a simple answer Shawn Michaels
calls up says listen I know you have
eric bischoff right I know you have
Bruce Prichard right wonderful people
great you've done amazing stuff in in
WWE WCW the whole the whole shebang
right Shawn Michaels this is Shawn
Michaels I'd like to come in
what would you say Travis we can make
what would you say can we make time no
yeah absolutely
okay we make some time but we made that
for you you made the time we made the
time Sam Sam I made the time this is
obviously the fault of faulty
communication oh it was a faulty when
you snubbed me at the radio row at
WrestleMania I think so cause like I
wasn't controlling who was coming up
into the thing you you but yeah but when
I said hey am i coming up and you're
like no we're done that's what you said
to somebody else
yo Joe pillows flat that when I walked
up to you and you said oh sorry we're
done well why did you say that yes I did
but I tell you why I remember why now
okay tell me why cuz the guy who did the
gear had already packed it up and you're
blaming the gear guy now guy had already
picked your guy's fault the show was
over but we would have record I would
have recorded something with you but the
gear guy had already picked up the gear
you don't have a cell phone that has a
recorder on it come on
professional bro you're such a
professional you're sitting here in your
pajamas
tell me you're professional are you
wearing something like that at
WrestleMania I'm sorry raw 25 rock 25 I
will I will have a far more formal
attire oh you will I will
so you okay so basically you respect WW
more than you do a Sirius XM that's not
true your own job that you go to which I
understand I love www is my job but if
I'm going to a job I go for the job I
want not the job I have and obviously
you just come in your PJs a great job
you don't look the part
what is the morning show host most alive
if I'm a morning show host I'd want to I
mean I always hear the the greatest
radio show host of all time
he always wears John Varvatos yeah but
he's got his own stylist why don't you
have your own style you know what
because he's because he's dedicated
right he goes one step above and beyond
yeah you gonna do that see you you just
basically are like I'm complacent that
could place it obviously your
complacency for me I burn your pajamas
to the show this is a sweatshirt it's
not pajamas it's the roots from that
could you sleep in it it really J's yes
it's really comfortable to sleep in it
is really calm yeah you look like you
just got out of bed Miz
I guarantee Howard Stern would never
look like he just got out of bed he
walks in there with such dedication he
goes in there with his John Burroughs he
has his own stylist exactly you right
why because he wants to be the best he
wants to be number one do you want to be
number one dress in a hoodie I'm already
number two you're here number two they
don't do ratings here I know that I had
a show on Sirius XM I always always ask
what are my readings we go we don't know
right you can see anybody so big yeah
they're like well one thing is there was
trending worldwide I go you're damn
right it was trending worldwide right
well you're a big deal I am a big deal
you're probably trending worldwide right
now thank you you're welcome
I think so I appreciate that but your
people need to tell my people when
you're gonna be in New York people you
were sitting here by yourself before I
walked the Travis dog in there that's
right you you have Travis dog great yeah
you got your Robin good that's great
yeah Travis dog takes care all that
stuff Oh does he
he's so you're the people he's defeated
on the microphone Travis tell me why I'm
he was too busy for me I was never told
that you were available nobody told us
you were available why your lawyer all
of you all of you on I of wires get
villa on the phone I'm done I'm done
with that no I'm done I'm done here I
actually have other media to do right
you're welcome for coming I appreciate
you and I hate you why do you don't like
me goodnight I don't like you I like
having you in the show
oh you do yeah that's what you're too
busy for me I'm not too busy you
I'm never too busy for you everyone
thank you very much I appreciate
everyone being able to listen to me but
Sam did not want me here that's not true
i barged in and made sure that my
presence was known that raw 25 is this
Monday at the Barclay center and
Manhattan Center Sam will be there
nobody will care nobody don't care
nobody will care that you're there why
how many people you think who do you
think will be a bigger star yeah where
Rosenberg I I mean who do you think I'll
tell you this I'm more like the
Rosenberg right you don't think so yeah
not by me why Rosenberg had me on for an
hour usually gave me a hug when I walked
in you looked at me you were deer in
headlights you're like oh my god he came
he knows I was too busy for bartosh
mousse you didn't have time you of
course you'd have time to smoothie bars
right you were a dear and hairdo you
peed it yourself a little that's why I'm
not standing up yeah that's what I think
I got these camo pants yeah yeah my
pants your PJs I told you I couldn't see
you because you're in your camo listen
I'm out I'm wearing these pants leaving
I honor the marine I have to go do more
media you're amazing at media that you
know I know don't don't try to try to
suck up to me now I can't wait for your
reality show you're gonna be a great dad
it's gonna be the worst it's gonna be
amazing worse but I hope you get booed
out of the building of our place well
I'm not gonna do an entrance and every
time as soon as you start talking how
people just start harassing you you do
oh yeah absolutely just heckling you the
whole time and you just buckle under the
pressure you turn red and you can't even
talk you're mixing up your words the
last professional broadcaster there's
not a professional broadcaster look at
the what you're wearing that's I
remember on the radio you can wear
whatever you wore you don't wear it you
don't see you know what that's your
mentality tell me that's the mentality
that you have the mentality I have I'm
on radio right now I'm wearing a suit
yeah but you were on TV before you're on
radio huh but I'm always wearing a suit
right
I'm always looking and prepared and
ready because I want people to know that
I'm a big huge star and I want to dress
for the job I want not the job I have if
people it doesn't have to be a suit by
the way right it could just be you know
something nice something comfortable
something that looks like you didn't
just get out of bed and walk to work
right yeah but if I wear a suit around
serious people are like who's the
douchebag in this
nobody around you don't have to wear a
suit did I say I didn't say yes I said
we didn't have to wear a suit and said
it would look like you didn't wake up
and come to work I don't it's not that
hard it's not that hard listen get a
stylist get something and dress for the
job you want if you come to Monday Night
Raw wearing that right I will give you a
Skull Crushing finale and throw you out
I won't be wearing this I'll be wearing
a nice formal and I hope that you'll be
not busy enough to maybe have a
conversation backstage with me maybe
anyone might be might be important
enough if you sound up to Nero listen
okay sorry must Shawn Michaels you okay
your people to let me know when you're
gonna be here because you live in Los
Angeles so I can't just be every Friday
being like hey miss is Miss here and cuz
let me show you like yes should all
right you earned it
all right so WWE do not get surprised
when every week every every what
Thursday Wednesday when do we want to do
this I'm gonna send an email every week
and I'm gonna go
hey Sam is it down hey and that would
never happen and you know what and I'll
get real it or we get relayed to me and
I'll be like you know what I feel wanted
okay because I want you to feel wanted
that's all I wanted that's all I wanted
that's all I wanted to feel wanted I
want you if you do that for me Rosenburg
welcomed me with open arms I couldn't
believe it
yeah he had a beautiful seat for me and
everything right it was amazing we had
an hour and I was livid my publicist
going okay how long are we doing this
show for and he's like as long as you
want literally I had an hour and a half
hour to have just talking you have just
shooting it with a guy you don't have
any guys conversation Oh guys girls
everything the whole shebang we're
talking about Kardashians talking about
sports talking about everything you I
walk in here I just want to smack your
face we don't don't smack my face you're
not going now we're in is totally fine
it's it's it's just a regular seat what
did you have a throne over there it kind
of fits Thrones it's satellite radio we
don't have throne well you know
satellites kind of big that's all I
listen to
it is when I'm driving you listen
emotionally I'm driving to reading
reading pH right for a live event I'm
going to be listen to Sirius XM and I'm
not gonna be listen to your show see I'm
gonna go on demand I'm gonna click on a
Howard Stern interview right so one of
the ones I don't know I just imagine
demand yeah I don't wanna listen to you
why do great interviews
do you do not do Howard Stern type
interviews I research the best of all
time we look Howard Stern's great okay
we got that but he works three days a
week at some point you're gonna need a
new content right you think you're the
guy I'm the guy dressed like that you
won't even yet you got in your
imagination you could be like oh but
Sam's wearing a suit or whatever he's
got like a nice sweater vest I'm sure
Baba Booey
hey it's also Travis dog who sure hit
him with the hind dog do you have any of
the wack Packers like what's your wack
back like we got Bobo
oh you have Bobo that like bubble the
clown
no no it's guy named Bobo you so you
stole Bobo from the show
you're stealing you're stealing material
from Howard no get your own I'm trying
to figure out what you're gonna do
that's different that that sets the
world on fire get Troy you got Troy hi
Troy cool hey chili talk to you about
tattoos doesn't mean that's all he's got
beer sees we get on we get into I was
the best tanning bed is he does talk
about tanning sometimes I just got back
from Miami oh he went on this trip you
know what he likes to do it likes to uh
fornicate we took him to that all the
time
excuse me fornicate with women like we
talked about that you know what I mean
we talk about all kinds of stuff but I
don't know how I can make you feel
wanted if you don't make me feel wanted
you don't listen to my show you know
what I'm doing here are you turning it
around on me you just don't you it's
been on for so long or too busy you've
known me for so long you don't listen I
know I don't listen your show because
you're too busy for me now I'm not too
busy yeah you would know that if you
ever listened to the show you know it
sounds Iike me he's a very busy man but
I don't think he's too busy for you man
what is he so busy doing he's got this
show he's got the show how many shows do
I have let's talk about this let's talk
about your life compared to my life okay
yesterday I was in Austin right I flew
here 1:00 a.m. got in Wright was up at
5:00 a.m. to do all media till 6:00 till
6 to noon noon and I will drive to
Reading PA do a live event then I'll go
to State College do another live event
then the next day I'll do another live
event then I'll do Monday Night Raw
brawl 25 they don't do the mix match
challenge on Facebook on Tuesday in
Washington DC I will fly to Los Angeles
on Wednesday Wednesday
I'll be doing a photo shoot with my wife
for miz and miz's which is our new
unscripted docu-series so when I'm doing
that Thursday I have meetings all day
what kind of meetings you know meetings
now I want to get some of those meanings
you don't have that type of you don't
have Friday I'm back on live events
again well then I'll be shooting the new
challenge probably next month all that
month while shooting miz and miz's while
getting ready for Wrestlemania tell me
your date today's you always hey no no
no no tell me your week now this coming
week yeah I want to hear your week okay
well I think Troy's coming over like on
Saturday oh my god and then after
today's happy Saturday yeah yeah I mean
watch like I don't know I don't know
what we'll do
what will you do well we'll probably
grab some food you know watch black
mirror on Netflix or something I do yeah
I got one more season of black mirror to
watch
I got he'll probably come down to my
home studio we'll do a show on YouTube
that's a short black mirror episode so
far the the jon hamm you look Jon Hamm
hour-and-a-half you liked that one loved
it real okay I loved it what was your
favorite I liked the one where there was
a kid that got caught yeah yeah yeah but
he got caught on the computer and then
like the whole time you're rooting for
this kid yes
and then they flipped it in well I can't
I don't want to spoil it for anyone but
is feeling what they thought like I was
like oh my god Wow
yeah like I cannot believe that just
happened that was incredibly made me
think like I was like wow that is just
it was so think it was it's just so well
done yeah so then so then Monday come
back to the radio wave Saturday and
Sunday your base is gonna binge-watch
Black Mirror you know Ozzy weekend I do
a busy weekend show me on who knows but
I'll do I'm sure I'll do at least one
maybe two shows from my YouTube studio
but you have a YouTube studio Sam
Roberts now on YouTube it's a might not
you have a YouTube 900 square foot
beautiful beautiful studio with a 990s
and 20 feet of it is the studio it's in
Westchester oh look at Chester oh look
at you so then someone's getting paid
less serious exam I see that can you see
that monitor right there yeah I can see
the monitor
okay scroll up on that Instagram account
look at the lookie you gotta come to my
house look at the studio that's in my
house I don't see it
there it is boys Troy slacking he's too
busy looking at his he's looking at
stats look at that wow that is a nice
dude he's a beautiful studio is that's
in your house it's in my house at your
living room
that's my basement you have a basement
bro I'm living large okay Wow yeah I do
not look at you and think this guy has a
basement it's like a man cave I like to
keep expectations low and is Millau down
there or is it just your it's nice only
my space my spot we have an imam
meatloaf no it's not my mom's it's not
my mom's okay but like yeah I mean my
wife can go down there but like oh we
have an 11 month old nothing for him
down there nothing for him nothing for
him now out know how much your wrestling
figures and stuff down there - I don't
know play with your toys no no he's a
lot allowed to play with you're a grown
man and you have toys you're like Zack
Ryder yeah yeah another I love that you
literally just like lit up when I said
that like it was like a compliment I was
but then crowning upon the fact that you
have toys you probably paid a lot of
money for those toys I've collected
oh my god you and Zack Ryder would just
have it talk about their toys they're
not collectible I clear the children's
toys that you play with when you're a
child and when you're a grown man you're
supposed to get rid of them they're for
display oh my god
and I got a bunch of sneakers down there
- all my sneaker colors wheat bro yeah
you Enzo can talk then
yeah you're putting me in good company
these are the superstars these are the
superstars yes so then Monday I'll do
the radio show here then I'll change
because I don't want you to see me
looking like a schlub go to the Barclays
Center for raw right so you wear a
flannel flannel shirt for your Sam
Roberts wrestling pocket I'm just
noticing what I'm look I'm looking at
what you're wearing and how you dress
for your in the not seem to know who is
that you're interviewing that's Ring of
Honor champion Dalton castle
okay I don't know that is yeah well
you'll get there you know you know I'm
at somebody I'll jump there event at
Barclays no that's that was there my
friend that's not what I meant scroll
down so you can so you can show Miz the
screen camp of my new year's show
because that way he'll that way there it
is see new year's tux look at you tie
undone because time done cuz you partied
your
in the new me when you look at Sam
Roberts you think dudes a party look
it's New Years lonely Eve it was a great
show it was by yourself yeah yeah so you
spent New Year's by yourself yeah yeah
dude not by myself with all the not
Samsonite's weren't you busy too you're
too busy for everybody else
DeNiro called said too busy sorry we
gotta take a break
I know here's your break I'm leaving Ron
25 leaving raw 25 hey you know thank you
for making time for me I appreciate you
making time for me miss Howe I did and I
think I see my break time they said you
have break time I go I'm going to Sam I
appreciate that
I know we're friends yeah that's you're
busy for me I think that you're gonna
win the Intercontinental Championship
I do do you want me to win or I do think
I'm gonna win I'm a bit of Miss fan
since before it was cool to be a Miss
fan oh you're so okay now you're just
kissing I used to tell the guy from
busted open the Miss is great and he'd
be like no news sucks yeah they always
they used to hate me now they like me
exactly I'm not one of those guys all
right you know me for a long time I've
known you in a long time right that's
why you snubbed me a bunch of time